[Music]
everybody it's Charlie
Sam Jackson is back in present day
dropping all kinds of f-bombs in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe so we got to
break it down he made a really teaser
repos
so I'll explain why this is important
that this is happening in London and not
in say like Atlanta where they film most
of their Marvel movies or in Los Angeles
or New Orleans where they were filming
Captain Marvel because they wrapped the
Captain Marvel movie a week ago so why
then is he putting on present-day Nick
Fury makeup for another film so if
you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the Marvel
videos there's a new round of that
infinity war blu-ray giveaway too I'll
explain at the end of the video so
timeline explainer in the last day
samuel l.jackson posted this on
Instagram he's in a makeup chair putting
on the regular Nick Fury makeup as if no
time had passed since the end of
infinity war even though there's
probably gonna be a bit of a time jump
at the beginning of Avengers 4 I know
there's lots of time-travel theories
floating around there but the important
thing here is to distinguish what's
happening from the timeline of the
Captain Marvel movie because Kevin Feige
confirmed that both Nick Fury and
Coulson would be de-age like they'd done
with Michael Douglas during the ant-man
movies or they've done with Robert
Downey jr. during Captain America Civil
War that confirms that pretty much the
entirety of Captain Marvel takes place
in the past barring a post-credits scene
in the future where she gets that page
from Nick Fury at the end of infinity
war it serves as the connective tissue
for Avengers 4 so that just means that
him putting on makeup for Nick Fury in
present day in a completely different
place than they were filming Captain
Marvel means that this is for a
different movie there's only one Marvel
movie filming right now in that a
spider-man far from home he's in London
they're filming in London so people like
wait a minute
does he pop up during the spider-man
film does that mean that he survives
Avengers 4 because he's one of the more
expensive Marvel actors and he's been in
so many films that there were a lot of
theories that they would just kill him
off and Avengers 4 and there wouldn't be
any more Nick Fury somebody else would
just serve that role like we have ever
Ross now who's sort of like the
version of Coulson and present-day that
just pops up in everyone's films but
he's not badass like Nick Fury nobody
can replace Nick Fury except for
somebody like Captain America that just
doesn't seem like the trajectory that
Chris Evans is Captain America is on so
that means that they either have to keep
Nick Fury around or just completely get
rid of that really badass F bomb
dropping character that pops up in
everyone's films and I don't think that
anybody wants that so I would be totally
cool if Nick Fury does survive Avengers
for just as long as they have a really
interesting way of using him it would be
fun to see him interact with x-men
characters when we learn about mutants
within the Marvel Cinematic Universe but
that's still a couple years off so in
addition to this he also posted some
more Easter eggs from behind the scenes
like Nick Fury has business cards but
the thing about this though is it's a
separate post and I think this is left
over from the Captain Marvel movie like
nobody in present-day carries around
business cards so that's why I think
that this is from the 90s
there's a Los Angeles address in Los
Angeles numbers so I think that because
they were filming Captain Marvel in Los
Angeles when we see that during the past
that's where she is like she pops up in
Los Angeles they filmed most of that
movie here because they got a tax credit
because most Marvel films film in
Atlanta so Captain Marvel got to film in
Los Angeles but it will also take place
largely in Los Angeles when it's not in
New Orleans so one this is just
hilarious because of the joke on it we
might not even see it during the movie
they might just flash it briefly and you
see it really small and frame and that's
the end of it but the address on here
they're a couple Easter eggs 9 0 0 1 7
is the same number as a jim Starlin
Captain Marvel comic the wilshire
address here is also the same address as
a real building in Los Angeles it does
kind of look like it could be a shield
office in real life it's the SGI USA
World Peace auditorium isn't Santa
Monica so there are only a couple of
reasons for all this to be happening
present-day Nick Fury so one yeah he
could genuinely show up during
spider-man far from home I'll explain
what that might mean but the other
option is is that he could be doing
reshoots for Avengers 4 so Avengers 4
and Avengers infinity war shot
back-to-back both in Europe but also in
Lanta but what I think is more likely is
is that he'll have some connective
tissue with spider-man far from home
because remember what happened during
spider-man homecoming the first bit of
that movie was basically a recap of
Civil War from spider-man's perspective
in what do we know is going to happen by
the end of Avengers 4 most of the people
that were turned to ash will come back
so Nick Fury might not be around for the
entirety of Avengers 4 like he's not
gonna come right back but I'm guessing
that somewhere either in the third of
the fourth act those people come back
Nick Fury starts interacting with
everyone again sort of reassume cz's
role as an authority figure than we know
spider-man
far from home is confirmed to pick up
minutes after the end of Avengers 4 even
though it's gonna be a separate movie so
remember a little bit of crossover the
same way they had with Civil War and
spider-man homecoming Kevin Feige
confirmed for the most part the pitch
for the movie is his spider-man is in
Europe on vacation with his friends so
unless there's some big time jump that
entire movie takes place during the
summer something gives him reason to
travel all over the earth because they
did say there would be a lot of
globe-hopping so it sounds like it
starts out as a vacation but then you
have the Mysterio plot in sinister six
stuff going on in the background because
the vultures coming back and that sets
him on a sort of globe hopping adventure
Nick Fury might be a point of contact to
help him do that even if he only shares
a couple scenes with them just imagine
the energy on screen when spider-man is
interacting with Iron Man I take that
back and now I'm right where I didn't
want me to be
this isn't Coney Island field trip is
just a one-way ticket you hear me
don't pretend you thought this line I
know you do I cannot really possibly but
it can't be a friendly neighborhood
spider-man if there's no neighborhood no
more pop-culture references from you now
imagine that instead of Ironman
it's Nick Fury in how would Nick Fury
deal with young spider-man
I sent the greatest soldier in history
to make sure that didn't happen
soldiers trust each other that's what
makes it an army not a bunch of guys
running around shooting guns last time I
trusted someone I lost if he's short
with Captain America during winter
soldier is gonna be hilarious to watch
him interact with spider-man so even if
he's not a big part of spider-man far
from home and it's mostly Avengers for
reshoots I think that there would be
some connective tissue tying him to
Marvel phase 4 the weirdest thing to me
and all this is that it seemingly
confirms that there will be Nick Fury
going forward they're just some
logistical issues with using samuel
l.jackson because at a certain point he
almost became as expensive as Robert
Downey jr. I think there's been some
backroom dealing to renegotiate that
stuff Kevin Feige did a recent
conference for The Producers Guild of
America where he did talk about some of
the financial aspects of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe where he said the
actual cost for them making movies
hasn't changed that much since phase 1
so like all the way back to the first
Iron Man movie it costs a certain amount
of money to make a movie the reason why
that number keeps going up so fast is
because of what he calls above the line
costs above the line costs are what they
have to pay the main actors so let me
know in the comments what do you think
that Nick Fury is suiting up for is it
gonna be reshoots for Avengers 4 or is
it gonna be Spider Man far from home
keep in mind too that there will be
reshoots happening for Captain Marvel
later this year because the movie comes
out in March next year but that probably
won't happen till much much later this
year there's a whole bunch of comic-book
news that just drops so I'll do videos
for that as quick as possible but
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Colin Dodd row please email me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact info there's a new round in
this video all you have to do to enter
those giveaways is just be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video so
click here to learn all about the
deleted scenes and the bonus features on
the Infinity war blu-ray and click here
for the ant-man of the wasp post-credit
scene thank you so much for watch
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]